- [Voiceover] Pop quiz.
You need some info on
the Futalognkosaurus,
the Baurusuchus, and the
Dicynodon, where do you go?
- [Voiceover] Wikipedia.
- [Voiceover] Thanks Nobumichi.
- Oh no problem.
- [Voiceover] How do we know what
these prehistoric creatures looked like?
- Lots of careful research
and attention to details.
- [Voiceover] Wait, wait how do you know?
- I draw them.
- [Voiceover] Wait really all of them?
- [Nobumichi] Well, a lot of them.
- [Voiceover] This is Nobumichi Tamura.
- Hello.
- [Voiceover] And he's
got a pretty cool day job.
- I'm working at the Advance Light Source
Lawrence Berkeley National Laboratory.
And my job here is to
take care of this machine,
the microdefraction and station.
- [Voiceover] The microdefrac, what?
- Microdefraction and station.
- [Voiceover] Ah.
But it's at night and on weekends
that Nobu channels the scientific know-how
into his dinosaur drawings.
- It's called paleoart.
- [Voiceover] My bad.
Paleoart is an original artistic creation
that depicts prehistoric life
according to the latest research.
Right Nobu?
- Exactly.
It's a combination of
science and creativity
so I basically read the latest discovery
on prehistoric animals
based on that factual data.
This is what I've been doing
for the last eight years.
- [Voiceover] And Nobu's
got a lot to show for it.
By his estimate he's
published over 1,500 drawings,
including some in this
book that he co-authored.
But it wasn't always smooth sailing.
The first drawing, that
was one of a dinosaur
called Chasmosaurus, but it was taken out
by the editors because it
wasn't accurate enough.
- [Voiceover] That's okay Nobu.
Can't bat a thousand.
- Is that a baseball reference?
I'm French.
- [Voiceover] I get it not
every baguette can be perfect.
- Why don't you?
- [Voiceover] Wait, wait,
wait, come back, come back.
Come back.